so today actually just since I don't
know everyone in the room I'm bill
Hirsch I'm the chair of the department
the director of the educational program
and today is the third of three days
where we have our summer interns present
their work what they how they spent
their summer vacation although maybe it
wasn't vacation but at least the ones I
work with have a good time and I
understand we also have some other folks
in the room which is this is the week of
our data analytics short course so I
welcome some of you who I probably know
by name but maybe not by face in any
case it's good Devin ice big audience
here so the usual procedure for these is
to have the students mentor present them
so I'm going to turn it over here to dr.
Chang who will introduce our first
speaker bill thanks well i am michael
chang and i have the pleasure of
introducing jessica Wallace Jesse and
you know but if you guys don't know
jesse is going to be a senior at the
University of Oregon and she's studying
biology and she actually had an
interesting bit of history that when she
was in high school she worked as an epic
trainer at st. Vincent's and learned all
about eh ours and workflow from that
experience so the group that I work I
work with a couple people who you guys
will know Michelle rye bar and Tom
yackel and we've been doing some
projects involving EHRs workflow and
modeling and Jesse worked on part of
this project that she'll talk about and
I'm she's done a really great job here
she's been fun to work with and if she's
integrated really really well with the
team so I'm just he once you go ahead
and talk about all this thing Thanks
thank you uh so has dr. Chang said I'm
Jessie Wallace and I was his intern this
summer and I'm going to be talking to
you today about EHR time demands for
ophthalmology documentation so I'm going
to start today by discussing I'm giving
you a
background history of electronic health
records and how that ties into the
project I worked on this summer which
was a two-part analysis of documentation
in ophthalmology I'll discuss my methods
for data collection and analysis as well
as the results I obtained from my
project and finally I will conclude with
why all this matters so electronic
health records provide many benefits
that are simply not possible with
traditional paper records the ability to
share patient data between multiple
providers is great and improve the
comprehensive care for the patients on a
larger scale EHRs allow us to extract
large amounts of data in the efficient
way that can be used to populate
registries and be used in all types of
research this can then not only lead to
better treatment for future patients but
also can help us to build more efficient
IT tools such as EHRs that can be used
for physicians in the future some of the
earliest EHRs date back to as early as
the 1960s however their implementation
in hospitals didn't start getting
significant attention until around the
early 2000s ohs um implemented its EHR
system epic in 2006 and was very
successful however this wasn't common
this wasn't common in all transitions
many transitions were met with
resistance from physicians who did not
want to move away from the traditional
paper records for fear of it not you
know being what they are used to and
impossibly taking up more of their time
in 2009 the federal government stepped
in and passed the HITECH Act in 2009
which was the purpose was to promote the
meaningful use adoption of these EHR
systems so starting in 2011 the federal
government used Medicare and Medicaid
incentive payments to reward physicians
and hospitals that chose to adopt these
EHR systems and starting this year there
will begin enacting penalties for
professionals and hospitals that are not
using them over this time period in
ophthalmology EHR
seen an increasing use from twelve
percent in two thousand seven to thirty
four percent 2012 and we can estimate
today that that is somewhere in the
realm of fifty to sixty percent but if
these are such great tools and their
incentives for using them why aren't
these numbers higher so ophthalmology
like other specialties has its own tends
to have a unique workflow and specific
documenting techniques that are not
always compatible with EHR systems that
can generally be built for unspecialized
primary care providers ophthalmology
clinics tend to have a complex workflow
which result from a high patient volume
as well as patients seeing multiple
healthcare staff during one visit and on
top of that some patients are come in
for dilated eye exams and dilation of
the eyes can add an additional 30
minutes to a patient is it these factors
that go into these complex workflows
tend to leave to inefficiencies in these
clinics that result in long patient wait
times and some doctors fear that the use
of EHRs will only make this worse for
documenting in ophthalmology using these
type of templates that I have up here or
a common practice before the use of EHRs
and while there are similar templates in
EHR systems they tend to not be as easy
to use or allow the same freedom that
paper templates do also many patients
have their eyes image during during
their visits and these are a big part of
making proper diagnosis however there
these images are not easily transferable
to the HR systems that we're currently
using some other concerns with
implementing EHRs and off maji clinics
include a fear of lower patient volume
as well as doctors having to spend more
time focusing on computer than a patient
in the exam room on top of that more
time documenting outside of work so the
purpose of my the project I was working
on was to hopefully provide some
evidence for how physicians were
interacting with
these EHR systems to either backup or
discredit these concerns um so as I
mentioned before I my project was a
two-part analysis the first part was a
time motion data analysis and this part
of the project was meant to answer the
question what percentage of exam time do
physicians spend documenting during a
typical encounter and then the second
part was an audit log timestamp data
analysis that was meant to determine how
much time a position spent documenting
per patient as well as one and where
they do this documentation finally I
wanted to bring these two analyses
together to give like a snapshot of how
optimal just interact with these EHR
systems so the first part of my project
was this time motion data analysis and
for this part I helped perform manual
observations of five providers from the
KCI Institute and the purpose of these
observations was to determine how
exactly a physician was spending its
time with with a patient to do this we
separated provider activities into three
broad categories which were documenting
talking and examining and during these
observations I would shadow of a
provider and time stamp one they would
switch from one activity to another and
then at the end of the day I would go
back through and calculate the times
they spent in each activity per patient
um since i joined this present eight or
project a little bit later and i had to
be trained to do these paired
observations and what this entailed was
I'm me and Sarah who's here I would do
observations together essentially and
would independently document you know
what the provider was doing and then
calculator time separately and compare
them to see if we were having any
significant differences in time what we
found that was that there were no
significant differences and that we were
essentially equivalent um so from that
point on I perform the rest of the
observations that myself some of the
tools that I used included the numbers
application on the iPad this is what we
use for a time stamping device as well
as Microsoft
for all time calculations and data
analysis and representation so this
graph here represents the results that I
obtained from these observations as you
can see we have the five different
providers and then in parentheses you
can see the average encounter time so
the average length of time they spent
with one patient then you can see that
these light blue bars represent the
percentage documenting the dark blue
represent percentage of time was spent
talking with patient and finally these
gray bars represents the percentage of
time that was spent examining one thing
to know there was a range of about
twenty one percent from provider c2
35-percent provider a of the time spent
documenting and in provider a the time
spent documenting trumped all other
activities on average we found that
providers were spending about
twenty-five percent of their time
documenting per one encounter while this
isn't a majority of their time spent
with the patient with already short exam
times which on average was about eleven
half minutes this is still a significant
amount of time and it's important to try
to figure out if there is a way to cut
this down so some of the limitations of
this this part of the analysis
determining when one activity started
and another ended can be difficult there
is often some transition time as well as
you know if a patient or of a physician
was multitasking and then switched just
doing one activity it could be difficult
to decide you know when that change
really happened and also since there was
only three categories it could be
difficult to place certain activities in
one of those three categories and in
that case I really just had to use my
best judgment and try to be as
consistent as possible we also felt as a
paired observations helped kind of
remind us that although there would be
some variance they probably did not have
a significant effect on our results
another limitation was that the numbers
app was a not the best time stamping
device and it was a little bit slow and
in the
that you had to input a lot of
information before being able to
timestamp and this was difficult when
the position was switching back and
forth between different activities
however it still got the job done so the
second part of this analysis was using
each our audit log data and EHRs while
they hold a lot of patient information
also holds a lot of information about
who's using them when we're so eh are
they actually record a timestamp for
every entry into their system which
create these audit logs that I've been
talking about um so that is a lot of
information and we were able to kind of
query these audit logs to find that x
from our five providers during the 2014
year that they spent you know entering
it into the EHR systems and we also used
some data from the Cognos database which
just essentially gives information about
patient check-in check-out times which
we use to kind of determine you know
when a physician was maybe in an exam
and then they were outside of that so
another member of our team Michelle rye
bar who's not here today came up with in
our script that allowed us to combine
these audit log in Cognos datasets and
from that we were able to determine the
average time that physicians spent
documenting per patient as well as when
and where this was performed we also
were work to try and validate these
audit log x with the time motion data
that we received in the main purpose for
this was that um you know there's a lot
more information that we can use from
the audit logs and the time motion data
studies were pretty time-consuming and
if we could get x from these auto logs
that matched our what we felt were more
accurate observation times then we could
be using these timestamps on their own
and they would be accurate so this table
is an example of the data we got from
one of the physicians we observed as you
can see it gives
the time spent documenting in an exam
room during business hours which but
outside the exam room and then during
non-business hours and for the purpose
of this project business hours is
defined as monday through friday 8-5 so
as you can see this provider spent about
3 minutes per exam documenting is
another 4 minutes outside of the exam
room but still within the business hours
documenting and then another minute on
top of that documenting outside of their
own normal business hours for a total of
eight point six minutes documenting for
patients while these numbers might not
mean much standing alone if we think
about one hypothetical clinic day which
we can say is about 40 patients on
average this results in 124 minutes
document documenting in exam one hundred
and seventy two minutes documenting
outside of the exam but still in
business hours and then another 44
minutes outside of business hours for a
total of three hundred and forty four
minutes or almost six hours of
documenting per one day of clinics so
that is a significant amount of time I
would say and although it's hard to
compare with you know with no baseline
and having these numbers now is
important because we can work to maybe
bring them down with newer and more
efficient majors so another chart that
we were able to produce from our data
was is kind of more comprehensive graph
that shows this is just for one provider
on all the hours of the day and then
what percentage of their total
occupation documentation was done in
each hour so as you can see them the
yellow and the bars represents an exam
time the light blues non exam business
hours and the darker gray was
non-business hours and so these are
interesting and to compare between
providers because it really gives you an
idea of the different strategies that
they employ to get their document
documenting done in the timely manner um
and our goal is to kind of be able to
create these graphs
and also the table I showed you
previously for a number of providers to
get an idea of you know the range of how
this document gets done so as I
mentioned before we wanted to try and
validate these EHR timestamps and the
main purpose for this was really to you
know prove that they were accurate
enough to stand alone and if we could do
that then we would wouldn't have to be
doing these kind of time consuming
observations and could rely on the vast
amounts of information that's already
present in the hrs so what we did is we
were able to compare the observed
documentation times in exam with the in
exam documentation times we got from our
audit logs and as you can see they are
not um they are not exactly the same
however we feel that and they are
similar enough and we can work towards
you know making them more similar which
will come with you know deciding how we
want to just use that our script that I
mentioned earlier to extract the data
that we need so some limitations to this
part of the study the biggest issue was
that the audit log x counted time stamps
in minutes and not seconds so this pose
two significant issues the that revolved
around determine the length of one
minute time stamps so when a provider is
documenting on multiple patients at the
same time which tends to happen more
outside of the exam room and outside of
business hours there can be multiple
time stamps within one minute but they
can be four different patients so for
example if there were eight times stamps
in one minute and five of those who were
for one patient and three of those were
for another what we ended up doing was
waiting these so we would give
three-eighths of a minute to that
patient and then another 582 the other
patient and then also we had an issue
with
stand-alone minutes which were more of a
problem for the in exam room documenting
and what this means is that there was
just one a one minute timestamp kind of
you know not near other time stamps that
could mean that the provider was
documenting for that whole minute but it
could also mean that they clicked one
button and it could have lost in a
matter of seconds the documents they
were doing so what we did is we decide
to count these one minute timestamps as
30 seconds we felt that this would
eliminate some of the variance in the
times that it could potentially be
another limitation was trying to get
this use the our script as like a
one-size-fits-all method on all these
providers have different workflows and
somewhat different business hours which
was significant when working with the
our code on determining we wanted to use
the same business hours and you know we
wanted to use like check-in and
check-out time from the Cognos data to
determine one a physician was an exam
versus outside of exam however this
wasn't always the most accurate
representation for each provider so
we're still working to kind of find a
model that fits all so why does all this
matter we wanted to provide some
concrete evidence for how physicians are
spending their time documenting in the
EHR and we saw this is important because
it can be used to advocate in the future
for more efficient and specialty
specific EHRs also we the validation of
EHR timestamps we think could be a
really valuable tool in the future
because if we can find a way to prove
that these timestamps and data are
accurate it can be used for vast amounts
of other research in the similar field
and finally I want to say thank you to
the project team I worked with Michael
Chang Sarah and Michelle robber who is
not here as well as dr. Thomas Yakel who
cystone the project thanks to all the
providers that allowed me to observe
them and hang around their clinic and
then also to the department the faculty
that have been really helpful over this
internship and all the interns and
special thanks to Emily for sitting next
to me all summer here and thank you for
the sentiment presentation thanks very
interesting results if your numbers are
correct you're talking about about six
hours a day documenting that there was a
paper published about a year ago that
caused a lot of unease because primary
care physicians were found in I don't
know if they use the same methods as you
guys did but to spend about thirty
percent of their time sitting in front
of a computer which alarmed a lot of
people although in reality physicians
even back in the paper day spent plenty
of time with records but if you're six
hours are correct i mean you're talking
you know fifty sixty seventy percent of
their time documenting and then that
leads to a more micro question which is
is it possible that when they're in the
exam room and they have the
documentation open that they're moving
back and forth between examining and
documenting so that they're really not
spending that full minute documenting
yeah so on that's a great question so
the in exam room stuff i didn't get a
chance to touch on this but we had what
kind of this hierarchy system for i mean
humans inherently multitask so if
someone was documenting and talking at
the same time we did count that as
documenting same for examining and
talking we kind of just said that
everything was going to trump talking
but in reality a lot of physicians I
feel like are very good now I being able
to document and interact with their
patient at the same time so yeah a lot
of that time does come from the in exam
documenting but it might not be as bad
as you know just staring at a computer
while the patient sitting there I think
especially now that it's been around at
least
ohsu for a long time physicians are good
at really integrating it into the exam
room have you checked back with these
clinicians and showing them your data
and how do they feel about it we have
not we actually are still going to
perform I think a couple more
observations before the summer so this
data is still a little bit preliminary
but there are a couple physicians who do
seem interested in the project and I
think they would love to see some of
these and you know images that we've
created and I think it's probably fine
to show it to them hopefully we'll be in
a paper someday what are some of the
things that you might suggest as
solutions to decreasing the workload um
well I think it's interesting to do this
study enlist in a specialty like
ophthalmology that does have its you
know unique issues and I think the
biggest thing is just going to be able
to build eh ours that are more efficient
and that's easier said than done but
also making them more specialty specific
I think the biggest problems come with
um you know right now they're kind of
built for more of a broad use which
doesn't really integrate well with a lot
of other specialties so I think the
biggest thing is getting the more
specific
so how specific do you think this is to
ohsu in kc eye institute compared to
other ophthalmology practices um you
know I'm not sure I think ohsu in
general has done a really good job with
training employees and integrating the
EHR system so it might not even be as
big of an issue as it is other places
and then there are still clinics who
have yet to make the transition but I
think regardless of how well it works
it's more of an issue with the with the
technology and finding a way you know
for it to really be useful for the
physicians that are using it so
definitely that's you know something to
think about everywhere but I think oh it
just use probably you know handling a
little bit better one of my my
ophthalmologist is one year subjects i
guess i can ask her the next time I see
you know she's too busy oops I just gave
her away good okay our our second
speaker since I was her mentor I will be
introducing Adrienne BB who has been
spending the summer and fortunately we
still have a few weeks with her working
on a project in the department that some
of you know bond it's actually pertinent
to the course that's going on this week
which is that last year we received a
couple grants from NIH to develop
curriculum materials in the big data to
knowledge program and adrian has been
working on various aspects of that she
comes to us she just received her
bachelor's degree from some of the tip
of my Whitman College and why I forgot
that anyways Whitman College and where
she majored in math and economics I'm
with that and she's been with us this
summer and is going to talk about the
work she's done in this open educational
resources project all right thank you
yes after her said I worked on the big
data to knowledge open educational
resources project and so the big data to
knowledge or bd2k is an initiative
through the National Institutes of
Health to quote enable biomedical
research as a digital and features
Enterprise facilitate discovering
support your knowledge and maximize
community engagement what this means is
that right now we're really good at
producing data and storing data but
there aren't a lot of resources for
actually using data especially in a
biomedical setting and so what our
project aims to do is to create open
access materials that anyone can
download to you learn from or manipulate
and teach the target audience is grad
students undergrad students and also
senior professionals who are just
starting to learn how to use big data
the ONC the office of the net of
national coordinator for health IT in
the past released similar materials for
data science but as I said quickly
changing field it's time to update those
so the timeline of our project is to do
two cycles over the next three years of
youth of a needs assessment development
and dissemination of materials and
evaluation and right now we are
obviously after july before november
we've really some modules and i'll get
to modules in a moment and so right now
we're just working on the first round of
development and so we answer the not me
the project leaders identified 32
modules in each module is a topic that
all surround clinical biomedical
research challenges of data the man
Semantic Web and ontology data modeling
and of course big data and so I came
into this project after a couple modules
already been developed and my goal for
the summer is to find data sets berkeley
big data sets and use them to create
supplemental x
sizes and materials to go along with the
modules so I started with a handful of
things to look into and you know that
quickly became a lot of rabbit holes to
delve into and you find a lot of
different sources of data out there but
then how do you decide which ones could
be useful in this setting and so I
developed kind of an informal honestly
somewhat subjective set of assessment
and so the four things the for visas big
data which kind of identify some
something as big data versus regular
data our volume velocity variety and
veracity volume is it big velocity is it
being quickly generated so not just a
stagnant data set from five years ago
that's not changed a variety other
different data types are there different
kinds of variables and veracity how
reliable is the source and then format
if i find it is that can i actually look
at it is that something is it in a file
type that i can download or that just
summary statistics that are locked in
the PDF file that i can't do anything
with and that no one can really learn
from in the context of big data
documentation is the data
well-documented are the variables
actually named and described right since
our project is all about open
educational resources we want it to be
something public that we can share and
that other people can use we have had a
little bit of trouble sometimes the
website will say yeah this data is open
for anyone to you but you have to apply
for it and you can only be a researcher
and then you can't actually share it so
we've not sure we haven't quite decided
how we're going to handle that if we're
just going to provide links etc and
topic this is about biomedical clinical
translational research account are kind
of our big things and so if the data set
wasn't really relevant to medicine
healthcare etc didn't really look at it
so getting into data documentation if I
find a data set I want to be able to
document in a way that the rest of the
team can use it especially after I'm
gone after this summer and so this is a
little snapshot of a couple datasets
that I found they have to do with
patient discharges in new york hospitals
the first one has to do with heart
earlier cases in the seconds to do with
newborns so i have a spreadsheet that
basically rates the four views of big
data and so for these data sets volume
pretty good volume couple hundred
thousand observations maybe not big big
big data but bigger than something to
help me a couple hundred observations
velocity its okay its release it's
released yearly pretty regular even
though it's not necessarily what we call
streaming data constantly being produced
it's not terrible variety about thirty
variables which is okay for asking this
is from the new york state health
department so probably pretty good
reliable source data management i don't
expect you to read all this but i'm just
going to tell you about metadata if
you're not familiar with metadata its
data about data so our data is the data
set and the data about that data is the
title who created it when it was created
etc dublin core is a great system of
using metadata it's about 15 categories
which are listed up here and it's pretty
easy to use it's pretty easy to find
most of the categories and it's easy for
someone else to come into and read and
so it's there's different kinds of
standards some of them have like 50
fields we decided on dublin core because
it's pretty widely used and accepted
either dictionaries not exactly the same
as metadata that this gets down into the
different variables in the data set so
this is going back to the same data set
that i talked about earlier heart
failure in new york hospital admissions
and each name is a variable there's a
bunch more once is just a little
snapshot and we talked and it's a great
way to document the definition the data
type of that variable and different
values that can take on for example the
age group age could mean anything if
someone who's never seen this data
before just use the variable age it
could be a continuous integer it could
be discreet integer but in this case
it's a categorical variable and it takes
on and basically a string so that means
it's a phrase and the different values
it can take on
r 0 to 17 18 to 29 etc so this is a
really good way to consistently and
thoroughly organize a data set and like
I said earlier another big part of what
I'm doing this summer is developing
exercises to go along with the modules
and so right now where I am in that part
of the process is essentially
brainstorming and working with the
principal investigators on the modules
that they have developed to create
exercises I'm not an expert in the
modules that they have developed so i
can only so far read through what
they've created and start thinking of
things on my own and so some examples
for module six which is clinical data
and standards related to Big Data a
possible exercise would to hat would be
to have a large set of possible
discharge data like clinical data and
you can query it so basically filter it
based on icd-9 codes standards and icd-9
codes if you're not familiar our codes
that have to do with diagnosis etc of
cases another possible exercise would be
in module 8 public health and big data
is to have a data set from social media
like Twitter posts there's a cool
website called top seed that has all
tweets ever Earl since 2006 and you can
use that for what's called digital
epidemiology so if you've heard of
Google Flu Trends basically that's
Google looking through what Google
searches have been done to try and
predict how many flu cases there are
pretty much at a given time and so we
could try to replicate something like
that with Twitter for example and so the
projects so far at the beginning of the
summer this is what our website looks
like it honestly it was just a place to
store what's already been done it's not
super pretty but with the help of our
instructional designer it's gone from
this to this so it looks like an actual
like a well designed website and so
internet willing I can show it to you
internet is willing so both designed
website we have the goals right up front
and how it's being developed we can go
over here we have the topics and so so
far on this website just the first one
has been released by medical clinical
and translational research and what we
also see all the other 31 topics that
are under development and we can view
the Const Capet content maybe a half and
here you can download the slides the
audio and all other resources so that
you don't so that you can use it
wherever you are and you can even modify
it for your own uses and now the
lectures we use a tool called articulate
and that combines power point slides
with audio so you have an online lecture
and so this is what it would look like
and what you can't hear because they
turn the sound off is Bill's voice
talking about biomedical clinical and
translational research draft one of this
presentation was just showing this and
listening to go pop and so now this
might be a little little boring just
sitting there reading what's on a
PowerPoint slide listening to someone
talk you can't even see have never met
but articulate has this cool cool called
interactions and what that is is a way
to engage with the whoever's listening
or watching your lecture and we can use
it to and the specific example that
about to show you we use it to use
cognitive load so basically what that
means is instead of just having a block
of text on a page you break that up so
that it's much more presentable to the
user and so this would be a before we
used an interaction it's just a lot of
text on a page but then here is an after
it was called a folder interaction so
for this case study and when we go back
we have a patient jessica has a disease
it's gotten worse it's expensive but the
Panda parents don't know what's going on
so this is just a lot it doesn't really
tell this slide doesn't tell a story but
now here's a little bit of background
information about Jessica here's her
diagnosis here's what's going on and
then here's the treatment so it's just a
way to break up the same information on
the original slide to a way that's much
easier to see and so the future work
I've got about three more weeks here and
what I'm going to do is hopefully learn
more about access and analysis of big
data something that honestly the project
is currently lacking in what's been
developed is that once you get your
hands on a big data set like a really
big data set how do you actually use it
we've so far and the project has a lot
of good theory about data management and
ideas about it but say you're not a
computer programmer and you find a file
that's about a gigabyte which this one
is about two million lines of code
Microsoft Excel can only open or rows of
data if rather Microsoft Excel can only
open about 1 million lines and so then
what happens when you get to the 1000
Genomes project that has 200 terabytes
of data and your computer maybe only has
like half a terabyte of storage so I
hope to work with shin dr. Shannon
mcqueeney about what to how to actually
get those get that big data working and
also I'm going to contribute to a couple
of the modules module 13 is version
control and identifies I'm currently
learning how do you get and github which
are ways to basically manage a project
especially with a team using version
control so it's for example if two
people are working on the same file and
then you try and upload that file back
to the group it basically manages who
sees what and what's the most updated
version is and also module 15 which is
data into landscape and so where to find
an access data that's basically what
I've been doing all summer so I feel
confident that all the
able to contribute to that one so yes
that's what I'm going to do for the rest
of the summer and I'd like to thank my
mentor dr. bill Hirsch and all the other
p is on this project Nicole vasilevsky
yarn Peterson dr. Melissa handle dr.
Shannon mcweeny and everyone has
contributed to the bd2k oer project and
of course to the fantastic summer
interns that i work with this summer
thank you
yeah it is available um this one yeah I
have the URL down here Skynet ohsu
reviews that beauty 2k yeah it is public
anyone can look at it and our next
benchmark is in November which is when
we have hoped to have all of the modules
and exercises at least in their first
stage of development for to be public on
the website yeah curious does this
website have an annotation of tools or
analytical techniques that have been
applied to different sex of big data I
don't think it does right now yeah we're
still working on actually getting the
modules out and we do have a whole lot
better still under development about
computational for computational or
analytical side of things
I guess how you fight then
thank you
all right okay I see cool well my name
is Stephen whoo and I'm an adjunct
assistant professor here at de maiz and
about a year ago got an ro1 grants work
on information retrieval from electronic
health records to do cohort
identification and so andrew has come in
and is working on the core
methodological research the core
interests of this research grant so I've
been very fortunate to be his mentor
andrew is a rising senior at Portland
State and studying computer science he
is a very very talented programmer he I
think got interested in it from the
gaming industry I think but has found
something more interesting and
meaningful in biomedical informatics
yeah so it's been a pleasure to work
with him and I think he's made more
progress than I expected in with three
weeks left he's made more progress than
I expected him to make all summer so I
really appreciate the time with him I'll
leave it to you injury okay thank you
dr. Luke so um espaço question I'm going
to be talking today about facilitating
court discovery their use of layers
language models so your first question
is probably going to be what the heck is
colored discovery so Kourt discovery is
identifying patients with their set of
attributes so for instance it can range
from stuff like demographic data to have
so age gender to stuff like you have
this patient has a certain set of
conditions or just patient has undergone
certain forms of treatment so here are
several examples of this so as you can
see here both of these examples have
treatment so PT MRI CT s or as well as
conditions so back pain for instance
example or cancer and and so you have
these
cords you want to discover so what you
do is you send a search request to you
have a big repository of electronic
health records that you can ask asked to
return data from so which electronic
health records match what I'm looking
for so you search this and ok so that
sounds like that works right except it
doesn't quite so the night way of
searching which is how a lot of search
engines work is you go by keywords so as
you start with something like heart
attack that separates into the words
heart and the tag and you ask the
database ok fine fine me documents that
have these two words in them and so so
one example where one match one word
matching gives you a point of 10 square
one would be ok so you have this this
right here suffering a heart attack and
that cause it's very complication so
this is the score up to it has two words
matching ok so clearly this works this
has a score greater than 0 so it thinks
it matches but consider this where you
have a knife attack right above the
heart that's also a score of two it has
the two words matching attack and heart
except it's not quite a heart attack
although it might lead to your heart
dying sure but it could are using this
Koree model for instance it would still
think it gives a score period thinks
it's equally relevant as a document that
exclusively says heart attack in it and
then as a further example consider
myocardial infarction is a different way
of saying heart attack suffers from a
myocardial infarction this again a score
of 0 because it doesn't happen we're
hiring attacking it and this is wrong
because it's still talking about heart
attack and wear something more subtle
like severe chest pain digit coronary
thrombosis is symptoms not heart attack
itself but it still suggests heart
attack so you would still want to return
the result in your search and this would
also get a search score of zero because
it doesn't have the words in it so the
solution to this is actually to use
cymatics to address the shortcomings
here so for instance with the limitation
where you can't find synonyms
you would normalize the data so you
would normalize heart attack and
myocardial infarction along with all of
its other synonyms into a common term so
for instance you can use concept view
IDs that all that matches this heart
attack and myocardium packaging both
match this continuity specifically or
you can use other codes for instance
icd-9 codes you can use I think we also
use sno-med or something and another
major limitation is you loose relational
data so what that means is for instance
you have you're looking for patients
with lesion on the hypothalamus and
you're looking for Legion hypothalamus
okay they had but for instance if you
were to have lesion on or Legion
proximal to the hypothalamus for
instance that would also match it with
how both of the major words you have
like Legion hypothalamus but it doesn't
have that actual relation which is on
top of not next to so so you would also
be searching for relations such as you
have a noun that the location of that
noun is on top of this other nap but so
I'm going I'm going to actually use this
term a lot subsequently cell layer is
basically a semantic type which is a
concept view ID a relation all right
actually these two aren't the only types
of semantics possible you can have
sentences you have parts of speech along
with a variety of other semantic tags so
the major limitation here is you still
can't only search a single later so if
you only searched single layer you lose
the benefits of having the other layers
for instance using the examples I gave
beforehand you if you could go with a
keyword search you miss out on synonyms
and you miss our relationships if you go
with a relationship search you are only
looking for the relation so if you're
looking at location of so you have this
is this mountain is located on another
now you're looking for that lesion on
the hypothalamus matches but so does
fracture on your uh oh I don't know
femur because both of these the location
you're looking for the location of
relation and you have a condition
location of other optics
it's like the end then as the riddler
example if you're looking for normalized
terms so where you can convert off the
synonyms into one common term you lose
granularity so you may wish you may have
symptoms and both so for instance with
the heart attack example you have heart
attack and then you have chest pain and
coronary thrombosis both of these match
heart attack but you may wish to give
more weight to something that says
explicitly says this patient has heart
attack as opposed to just describing the
symptoms so the solution to this is
actually to just search for multiple
layers at once and rather than searching
for keywords so rather than searching
for this specific the specific term
within a given a semantic type we look
for multiple combinations of these so we
look token would just be we have this
word within the semantic type we can
have windows which is we have we have an
artifact which is a token window or
phrase as listed here with an artifact
that contains a set of other artifacts
so for example this sentence we want to
look for this sentence that contains
word one word to word five right or we
can have a phrase which is basically two
artifacts next to each other let's say
and within a given distance to each
other so we say i want this term right
next to this term i want part right fall
immediately by attack I don't want it in
any other order I don't want any words
in between them so and then beyond that
we also want to give each document a
score right so when you ask a search
engine for something you get a list of
results and you want you want the list
of results you want the most relevant
thing to be first up because you don't
want to scroll through 50 pages of
things to fight what are you looking for
right so this is an example scoring
model and you may be asking why am i
showing you this is equation because
because obviously you don't know what
any of these terms mean yet so I TF here
means term frequency which
actually how often the artifact we are
looking for it appears in our document
CF means collection frequency so how
often the artifact we are looking for
appears within our entire document index
so the important thing to note here is
that we actually compared it the two
together so if we have a dark turn that
doesn't occur often within our document
but occurs very often within the the
entire document index so our other
documents all contain a lot of this term
we may wish to score differently come as
opposed to if we have a term that occurs
a lot in with in this document but
doesn't occur at all within the document
index of the whole because in that case
in the latter case it would be
considered pretty significant and so me
here in this case would just be the
weight between the design well it's a
form of waiting the two together wedding
the local document frequency as opposed
to collection level frequency so I've
talked so far about the concepts behind
when I'm working out so I'm actually
going to talk about what I actually
worked on this summer which is actually
implementing all this within the search
index so in order to cover this I'm
actually going to cover how the
searching work so you start with a basic
text query which I which then gets
converted into a layered query in a
sense which basically I want to look for
this window of a sentence within that
contains this word and then that gets
sent to a document index which is
basically a big collection of all of
your documents so all of your documents
your health records in this case right
and then that document index gets you
back a ranked list of results so so what
we use have to document index so I'm
going to actually going to start with
I'm actually going to start with the
third third box here document index what
we actually use last Bachmann index it's
called the elastic search which is a
inverted index what that means is
rather than searching through all five
million of your documents word for word
for each term you use store okay so
weird one this word one is contained
within documents 1357 so obviously you
wouldn't want to look through 50 million
words each search so instead this
mapping allows you to get better
performance another thing that gets
stored is the term positions which is
other actually rather important so it
says this word starts at position 1
within this document this other words
starts at position 3 and I mean that's
important because if you're using
something like phrases you have to know
how far they are between each other so
okay so elastic search to support this
but it also has major limitations so it
doesn't actually support multi-layered
searching per se so it doesn't
understand the concept of layers and
overlap what that means is it will
always increment each position by one so
sentence one sentence to sentence one
will have position one since it's too
will have position too but for example
sentence one may contain five basic
words sentence to my contain seven and
so sometimes when you want to start a
position one and sentence to you want to
start position six right because one two
three four five minutes in these two
sides so I cannot support a token in one
layers spending multiple tokens in a
different layer basically and then the
other major major limitation is that it
can't support multiple tokens at the
same place so for instance chest pain
may correspond is a symptom of heart
attack right but it can also be a
symptom of a variety of other things
like I'll know the lung cancer let's go
with that so it can have multiple
concepts within that same location and
the last research doesn't understand
that so in order to support this support
what we actually want to do we have to
change the way documents or index and to
do this we first determine the base
layer so typically we use just
the plain tex of a document so English
droids and then after that for all the
different semantic pipes we first we
started given terms of tokens with the
given position so their actual position
they're starting location compared to
the base layer so this this token starts
at position 1 this token starts to add
word six of our base later and then we
also start talking length so this token
extends for six words with in our base
later so we covered indexing now and I'm
going to move on to scoring so after we
put the talking to new index we actually
need to be able to change the way that
it returns matches so come frequency for
anything that isn't basically i want
this word in this this layer it's
actually completely off in elastic
search so we had to fix that and
actually elasticsearch doesn't even
calculate collecting frequencies which
as you may have noticed before it's
actually pretty important i was going
model and so and it doesn't even use the
formula we actually want to use so the
biggest problem actually is that
elasticsearch really does not want to
let us change these things so our
solution to this was actually to write
our own version of the phone query
basically that supports smashing our
artifacts so we manually defined within
each of these artifacts I have this word
in the stories i want you to find the
position things compare them and then we
have to advocate the frequencies
correctly as well so we did it through a
two part system the first past we
calculate document frequencies and then
at the same time we also some of the
respective frequencies into a big
collection frequency and then honest I
can pass through we actually score the
documents with the clerk and frequencies
and the document frequencies
and so the sound sign it works right
Biggs from here is that it's actually we
have 10 million documents in the Ovation
see database so if we were to actually
take 10 milliseconds to do each of these
things this would take 20 hours and
you're getting get it bunch of
pissed-off researchers basically so so
and we have to go through this entire
thing for three operations when we
searched things you have to go through
the entire thing twice as I outlined
beforehand and actually when we index
things because we're actually printing
document inside the database itself we
actually have to go through this as well
right and we have to change each of
these documents individually and
actually convert them into a format and
can researched so performance is
actually really really important to this
case and we actually solve this problem
by changing up the algorithms to make
them run faster as well as paralyzation
so that we can process multiple
documents at once basically the second
biggest problem is extensibility so
unfortunately I'm unable to convince 08
SED hired me for the rest of my life so
I actually have to stay here and I can't
stay here and change things to fit
exactly what it's needed so we had to
make ensure that the software we wrote
is easily adaptable to our needs without
having to rewrite everything because
that would be a waste of weight right so
we have to be able to support changing
what specific semantic layers are stored
within the index easily without changing
any code so we accomplished that using
configuration files and then within our
queries in themselves we have to find
the artifact types so if we want to go
beyond just phrases or totems or
sentences we have to be able to define
that while still allowing them to be
compatible with our existing stuff and
we also have to support easily change in
a formula because the model actually
showed you earlier it's not the only
model that's possible so so I've covered
what we finished so far so I'm actually
going to cover what we're working on in
the future as well as well right now I
guess so I cover
the latter half of the earlier search
pipeline so now I'm going to cover query
reformulation which is what we were
working on query formulation is
basically the conversion of a plain text
query to a layered for query that we can
use to return results and to do that we
actually well you may have noticed that
there was a new parameter earlier in the
model that basically defines a weight we
don't know the value of that that weight
so what we were planning on doing is
we're planning on using an experimental
value and then submitting that to a
trick database so what that is is the
trike index has a set of predetermined
golden standard results so we already
know if I send in this query I want
these results back so so we send out in
with our Laird query and we compare our
results to see ok so what documents do i
have that actually match what i want and
and then we repeat we change our query
model we change our weight and then we
see we see okay does this work better if
this works better we keep repeating it
up until a certain threshold is met and
then we send that a threshold or the
weight that we determined to be optimal
per se to the ohsu data because it's a
significantly large it is it takes it
takes longer so we send that to ohsu
data and then we compared with results
from a relevance assessment to determine
how accurate it is to what we actually
want so I would like to thank dr. woo
for everything my mentor at this
apartment for xperia opportunity to be
here as well as my fellow entered and
that concludes my presentation so thank
I'm scribbling aren't I Oh what date is
it it says 27 right
you